Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Neues Jahr, neues Glück, alter Salon.
In den USA könnte es auch ein neues Glück dann geben, aber zunächst allen ein gutes neues Jahr und dir auch.
Gutes neues Jahr allen zusammen dir auch, Wolfgang. Hoffentlich können wir ja bald wieder Schnitzel essen. Noch allerdings liegt die Schnitzelbude nur in meinem 15 Kilometer Radius.
Gut, dass dieser Radius nicht für das virtuelle gilt. Würde man ja momentan der Bundesregierung in ihrem Aktionismus auch noch zutrauen, weil man irgendwie versucht, etwas zu tun. Man weiß gar nicht, bringt es was, aber es sieht auf jeden Fall so aus, als hätte man was getan. Und deswegen gibt es dann diese 15 Kilometer Regelung, wobei ich eigentlich dachte, es hätte sich schon herumgesprochen in den vergangenen Monaten, dass gerade problematisch ist, wenn Menschen beieinander wohnen, gute Nachbarschaft pflegen und sagen, ach Mensch, der Peter, der kann doch mal gerade rüberkommen, der hat doch nix. Und der wohnt nicht 15 Kilometer entfernt, aber ich hab's auch dann nicht begriffen, wie man eigentlich eher sagen müsste, trefft euch nur, wenn es 15 Kilometer entfernt ist. Also dass man noch mal überlegt, ist das sinnvoll, da hin zu fahren und so. Ist der Mensch denn vielleicht getestet, hat er was, gibt's da Risikofaktoren, während man gerade so in nächster Nähe sich anders verhält. Ich hab's jetzt auch gehört von Freunden, mit denen ich telefoniert habe und die dann sagten, ja, jetzt waren ja eben noch gerade die Nachbarn da, mal Krippchen gucken. Und dann sagen die auch noch, ja, die kennen wir noch gar nicht so gut, denn wir sind hier umgezogen. Also wissen sie auch noch gar nicht, wie die sich so verhalten. Und da bestehen ja die größten Gefahren.
Ganz genau, wir wissen einiges über das Infektionsgeschehen, aber immer noch zu wenig, um eine politisch wirksame Entscheidung zu treffen, weshalb wir nach härter, schärfer, länger einfach alles noch mal doller gemacht haben und eben nicht ins Wirksame gegangen sind. Denn es ist tatsächlich, das muss man sagen, es ist dieser Nahbereich. Und jetzt kommen einige Paradoxien. Wenn wir Lockdown machen, das haben wir hier auch schon häufig diskutiert, dann haben wir ja mehr private Zeit und weniger Zeit in Öffentlichkeit. Das heißt, umso mehr Lockdown, umso mehr Entwöhnung von der Maske findet auch statt. Umso mehr wir Lockdown machen in Deutschland, umso weniger tragen wir Maske. Und umso weniger sind wir dann auch bereit, in dem Moment, wo man sich denkt, ich zieh sie jetzt doch mal auf, sie dann auch aufzuziehen. Ich bin ja, wie ich schon gesagt hatte, zu Weihnachten nicht verreist, meine Kinder aber schon. Und als sie ihre Oma mal getroffen hatten, hatten sie tatsächlich, nachdem sie sich zum Spaziergang draußen verabredet haben, um drin das Geschenk zu überreichen, ihre Maske auf. Und ich frag mich ehrlich gesagt, wer welches Kind in Deutschland, kann ja jeder bei sich selber überlegen, wer hat seine Großeltern besucht und hat dabei indoor keine Maske aufgehaben. Und das ist das unvernünftigste Verhalten überhaupt. Da kommt man mit 15 Kilometer Regelungen nicht ran. Da muss man auch mal sagen, wo kommt die eigentlich her, die 15 Kilometer regeln? Mules hat das gestern auch noch mal auf Twitter geteilt. Das ist ein, wie er sagte, Geschenk aus Bautzen. Denn in Bautzen, wie wir wissen, Inzidenzen 700, 800 und höher 7-Tage-Inzidenzen. Da gab es also Lockdown-Maßnahmen, die tatsächlich Bewegungsfreiheit eingeschränkt haben. Das heißt, diese 15 Kilometer kommen aus einer Region, wo Gerichte schon mal überprüft haben, was ist eigentlich zulässig, erklärbar. Es gibt ja die juristischen Termini dafür. Es muss so, so und so sein. Und dann ist es auch verfassungsrechtlich gedeckt. Und die 15 Kilometer sind, wie die 800 Quadratmeter im Laden, schon mal juristisch an einem Ort mit einer spezifischen Inzidenz von einem spezifischen Gericht ausklamüsert wurden und gelten jetzt deutschlandweit, weil man dachte, damit sind wir rechtssicher. Also es ist sozusagen aus der Luft gegriffen. Und ja, Bodo Ramelow hat sich die 15 Kilometer gewünscht, damit die Sachsen nicht nach Ostthüringen einfallen, um beispielsweise wie auch immer einzukaufen. Da macht es auch absolut Sinn, weil wenn 15 Kilometer weiter die Inzidenz siebenmal so hoch ist wie bei dir zu Hause, dann macht es wirklich Sinn, einfach zu sagen, Leute, das ist so hoch, wir machen jetzt eine pauschale Regelung. Warum wir das in Frankfurt bei einer Sieben-Tage-Inzidenz von aktuell, ich kann ja mal nachgucken, 106, 8 machen sollten, weiß ich nicht, zum Glück ist man noch mal auf die 200 hochgegangen. Sonst hätte man das ab 100 gemacht. Das hieße jetzt auch in Frankfurt. Gölte dann diese Regelung. Das wäre doch ein bisschen übertrieben, finde ich.
In der Tat, es ist auch merkwürdig, dass wir über diese Paradoxien so wenig nachdenken. Ich hörte eben ein kurzes Interview mit einer Friseurin im Radio. Und die wies daraufhin, ja, sie könne einige Maßnahmen schon verstehen, möchte aber darauf hinweisen, dass die Schwarzarbeit unter Friseuren gerade so langsam in Gang kommt, da viele Leute auch fast ihre Friseure unter Druck sitzen, sagen so, ich möchte aber die Haare geschnitten bekommen, jetzt komm doch bei mir vorbei. Und da werden dann ganz viele Regelungen nicht eingehalten, die aber gelten, wenn man jetzt einen Salon betreiben würde. Und ich hab das ja auch schon mal, glaube ich, hier geschildert, wie vorbildlich ich das erlebt habe. Also ich kam mir fast vor, dass ich dachte, hoffentlich sind alle OP-Selle so sauber, wie es bei meinem Friseur zugeht. Und das sind ganz viele Gefahren, die da kommen. Und dass man sagt, naja, gut, der schneit mir ja nur mal gerade die Haare, ich lass ihn mal rein und hat man da eine Maske auf und diese Dinge. Was ist da desinfiziert, was nicht? Solche Geschichten blühen da natürlich. Und das ist ein ganz großes Problem. Alles, was öffentlich ist, kann besser kontrolliert werden, bis hin zur Maske dann auch. Aber mein Unwort des Jahres kann ich jetzt schon am 6. Januar, glaube ich, verkünden. Und zwar, Unwort des Jahres, Impfnationalismus. Das fand ich wirklich hochinteressant, dass man nochmal ganz schnell versucht hat, die Kritik an der Besorgung von Impfstoffen sofort in so einen Nationalismus abzutun. Ich glaube, die meisten Leute, die sich da kritisch hervorgetan haben, den ging es ja nicht darum zu sagen, wir Deutschen haben als erstes diesen Impfstoff verdient, sondern die Kritisierten, wie die EU damit vorgegangen ist, dass die EU da viele Patzer sich erlaubt hat, dass man auch mal generell nachdenken kann, wie kann man den Prozess beschleunigen, was kann man noch wirklich aufbauen an Infrastruktur und und, dass man aber da nochmal versucht hat, dass man das einfach so als Nationalismus abtut und damit die rechte Ecke schiebt, um sich damit vor aller Kritik zu immunisieren. Das fand ich wirklich skandalös, dass das teilweise gelungen ist und dann war ich sehr froh, dass aber auch Leute, die eher dem linksliberalen Spektrum zu zuordnen sind, wie jetzt ein Georg Restle oder ein Florian Schröder, ganz klar auf Twitter gesagt haben, nein, man kann durchaus die EU kritisieren, man kann die Bundesregierung kritisieren und man kann kritisieren, dass das hier mit den Impfungen zu langsam geht und dass zu wenig besorgt wurde, ohne Nationalist zu sein.
Genau, wir kommen aufs Impfthema gleich im Salon zurück. Es gibt einen Text, der hat mich zum Weinen gebracht, muss ich wirklich sagen. Und zwar aus zweierlei. Erstens, tiefe Betrübnis darüber, dass wir tatsächlich zugelassen haben, dass in Amerika 360.000 Menschen sterben. Und mit zugelassen meine ich, hätte man auch verhindern können. Und auch durch Freude einfach. Also ein Text, der wirklich Freude macht, im Sinne von, die nächste Pandemie soll mal kommen. Und dann überlegen wir mal, wie wir das dann machen. Denn diese politische Streiterei ist, wie soll man sagen, wir sind ja, wir arbeiten uns ja erst langsam an den Kern. Du hast jetzt sozusagen, das ist so die Eingangstüre. Diskussion auf Twitter zum Thema Impfnationalismus, damit irgendwer sich irgendwie immunisiert und vielleicht noch mal schafft, bis Februar so eine Diskussion zu verzögern. Und dann läuft es vielleicht mit der Impfung und der Dampf ist schon aus dem Kessel. Aber wir haben ja eine EU-Kommission, die tatsächlich so proporzmäßig Impfkäufe auf Länder verteilt hat. So, und dann wollte Macron eben auch das Sanofi zum Zuge kommt. Und jetzt liefern die aber nicht, weil die haben gar nichts in petto. Und wir haben weniger bestellt bei denen, wo die Kandidaten wirklich aussichtsreich waren. Wie aussichtsreich die waren, das klären wir gleich im Salon. Das ist wirklich, da kriegt man wirklich Tränen in den Augen. Ich sag's euch Leute, kommt in den Salon und hört euch das gleich mal an.
Es ist so wunderschön, dass du da sagst Tränen in den Augen, denn ich habe auch dazu einen Text. Denn mit den Tränen in den Augen sagst du uns jetzt gleich, das ist ein besonders wichtiger Text. Denn ich habe sogar Tränen in den Augen gehabt und dieses Argument Tränen, das hat sich Thomas Frank mal angesehen und hat da einen sehr polemischen Text zugeschrieben mit Blick auf die amerikanische Außenpolitik. Also wir jetzt gleich Stefan emotional und ich komme dann mit einem polemischen Text von Thomas Frank. Aber wir müssen noch ganz kurz sagen, du hast es im Vorgespräch gerade ein paar Minuten vorher noch erzählt, es zeichnet sich da in Amerika etwas ab, das man nicht erwartet hat. Nämlich, dass die Demokraten wirklich mal richtig viel Macht plötzlich bekommen.
Es ist die überraschendste Meldung überhaupt und man kann sie zu diesem Zeitpunkt, 10.28 Uhr am Mittwoch, noch nicht bestätigen. Aber laut New York Times ist der eine Senatorenplatz in Georgia schon an die Demokraten gegangen. Das heißt, es geht jetzt 49 zu 50. Einer ist noch varkant, es sind 98 Prozent der Stimmen ausgezählt und man führt mit 50, 15 Prozent auf Seiten der Demokraten, das nämlich John Ossoff dort, David Perdue oder wie auch immer, kann man jetzt auch vergessen, weil es wahrscheinlich abgewählt, raushaut aus dem Satz, womit es 50-50 steht, 50 zu 50 und Kamala Harris immer den Tiebreaker machen kann, was wirklich eine kleine Sensation ist, denn wir hatten ja schon mal einen David Axelord Clip gespielt, wo er ganz klar gesagt hat, ja, Biden wird Präsident, aber ohne Senat kann er gar nichts machen. Da kann er Executive Orders unterschreiben und hoffen, dass sie nichts kosten, weil diese Budgets nämlich nicht da sind. Also das ist sozusagen aber und auch dazu heute einen sensationellen Text im Salon. Ich verrate gar nicht weiter. Das ist wirklich ein Spektakel. Was ist, wenn wir alle tatsächlich, kann man sich vorstellen, dass wir alle nur noch in einer Simulation leben, politisch. Damit meine ich nicht diese Elon Musk, das Elon Musk Theaterbissende von und so, sondern kann es sein, dass wir in einer Welt, in der wir zehn Stunden am Tag auf unsere Handys schauen, nur noch in einer virtuellen Politik, Dream Politik, so wird es genannt, leben. Das klären wir gleich. Da gab es einen ganz sensationellen Text von einem Intercept-Autor, der sich auf ein Buch bezog, das hier sich auch als Kandidat für Salonlektüre anbietet. Wir kommen gleich darauf zurück. Gut, jetzt haben wir euch hoffentlich genug geteasert.
Jetzt geht es aber erst mal in die Zukunft nach Shenzhen.
Genau. Shen-Shen, wie ich gehört habe.
Manche sagen auch Chan-Chan. Wir werden es wahrscheinlich irgendwie falsch aussprechen. Aber es ist wichtig, sich mit dem Thema und dem Buch von Wolfgang Hirn zu befassen. Damit starten wir.
Und damit kommt ihr in den Salon. Wir haben euch hier nochmal angeteased und wir sagen, wir machen hier das Angebot. Erstens, dass ihr den besten deutschen Podcast unterstützen könnt. Und zweitens, Tränen in den Augen, ohne TikTok, ohne Instagram, ohne irgendwas Visuelles. Tränen in den Augen durch Hörerlebnisse intellektueller Natur.